séquence ping pong ce soir je reçois
herring lunettes pour son livre être
riche un tabou français paru chez albin
michel et va répondre à une critique de
guy konopnicki de marianne et rigoler
bonsoir bonsoir
alors avant qu'on s'occupe de la
critique de cannes petit je vais faire
un petit quizz un petit s à propos de
citations qui sont dans votre pays vous
allez me dire de qui c'est je demande à
tout le monde d'écouter
c'est un jeu pour tout le monde l'euro a
été inventé pour rendre le salaire des
riches
six fois moins indécent ça c'est très
drôle c'est avec bdc beigbeder dans 99
francs une qui est moins drôle à mes
enfants une intéressante surtout le
personnage la droite a touché le fond de
la piscine maintenant elle creuse ah oui
c'est sans tenir andré santini sur le
problème de l'argent justement wii qui a
été mis en examen à evry bah oui
l'argent est préférable à la pauvreté ne
serait ce que pour des questions
financières qui disent à qui l'état qui
dit ça c'est woody allen bari woody
allen
bien sûr on sent le talon un voile alors
nous revenons un peu à ceux être riche à
un tabou français alors l'impression
l'on vous creusez un filon parce que il
ya eu être de droite un tabou française
que cette début d'une collection
non je vais m'arrêter là mais c'est vrai
jeu pour moi je sais moi qui suis un
type qui est un peu le coeur à droite et
qui ce libéral c'est les deux grands
verront que j'avais envie de faire
sauter sur comment on a le coeur un
petit peu je vous l'avais beaucoup à
trois mains nues en gros je suis un peu
libérale mais c'est vrai que dans un
monde où toutes les télés djetou
l'intelligentia tout le monde de
l'édition de la culture intérêts plutôt
à gauche c'est vrai quand sa belle au
crac
oui
bon bah on va écouter ce que dit bien
sûr guy konopnicki donc vous imaginez
bien qu'il n'est pas d'accord avec vous
parce qu'il est avec marianne mais parce
qu'il a quand même tout un passé de
militant et une pensée donc
écoutons guy konopnicki sur le sujet on
y va brunet vous pensez qu'il ya trop
riche
c'est toujours un tabou français et vous
chercher les origines du tabou alors on
va commencer par les plus récentes vous
dites il ya cette phrase du général de
gaulle qui est en exergue de votre livre
et qu'on retrouve à l'intérieur du texte
celui de goldie en 1944 l'ennemi de la
france mon ennemi l'adversaire plus
exactement ça a toujours été l'argent
oui c'est vrai mais mais de vous le dis
ça mais vous pensez pas qu'il ya quand
même des raisons de dire ça est ce qu'il
a vu arriver la france de l'argent à
londres ils sont jamais venus et puis
l'argent c'est aussi la france qu'ils
jettent dans le marché noir au lieu de
résister cette partie de la france qui
est d'abord l'argent d'accord pas
d'accord alors bon bien évidemment de
gaulle c'est un personnage transversale
qui transgresse les schémas de gauche
droite et il plaît aux gens de gauche de
gaulle y plaire aux gens de gauche à 6
de leurs personnages politiques des
français
tout à fait et c'est ce qu'aime
konopnicki chez lui c'est cet homme
austère et il est séduit par sa bravo
une analyse plus fine nous montre de
gaulle sur la fin de sa présidence en 67
68 69
très soucieux de faire évoluer la france
de la sortir de l'économie planifiée de
gaulle idée plus de 30 % des
prélèvements ça devient insupportable
la personnalité de gaulle aurait évolué
j'imagine vers une culture plus libéral
et plus ouverte vers le vers l'économie
de marché j'en suis convaincu alors là
bien évidemment il a beau jeu konopnicki
de dire tiens à toi t'as vu toi quel
droit tu toi qui es libéral regarde-t-on
icône de gaulle lui même mais il
n'empêche que devaux letombe sont des
projets plus progressistes qui sont
l'intéressement et quand on tombe tous
arrivés après il balaye tout ça qu'on
puisse jouer plus à droite que de gauche
j'aime vous l'entendre dire
moi j'aime beaucoup confie de l'homme
qui amène le design à l'elysée c'est un
vrai président moderne
la deuxième chose par exo là vous dites
qu'à l'école on m'a fait lire zola et
pas balzac et surtout manifestement pas
oublié de vous faire lire pascal parce
qu enfin qu'est-ce que les provinciales
qu'est-ce que port royal qu'est-ce que
jansénisme qu'est ce que le
christianisme alors ce tabou de de la
richesse il vient de l'histoire
chrétienne de la france et est ce que en
touchant à ses fabuleux de voir les
intellos de gauche les mao l'étroite sco
les anciens coco tous les intellos de
gauche qui qui soudainement en 2007
tombe amoureux de la religion catholique
en irak l austérité
quelle relation distanciée avec l'argent
est patent enfin ça c'est quand même et
guignolesque c'est épouvantable
l'histoire de ce pays par rapport au
problème de la richesse et de l'argent à
mon avis elle est assez simple à
décrypter
il ya la tradition chrétienne catholique
dia le bon vieux socle rousseauiste ou
bon temps gustin l'argent ne doit pas
faire de côté et puis à 45 c communiste
puis plus tard près 68 les mao qui vont
s'installer douillettement dans les
petits chaussons laissé vacant de la
tradition catholique est là et bien
comme les cathos
ces cocos ils vont simplement d'erreur
l'argent c'est nauséabond ça pue à
l'argent roi
le libéralisme l'exemple américain que
l'horreur etc il ya la même distance
nauséabonde avec l'argent chez ces gens
là on a un problème parce qu
intellectuellement on n'arrive pas à
considérer que l'argent peut être
vertueux écoutant on touche pas tout
simplement au christianisme voire même
judéo christianisme est ce qu'il faut
aller au culte du veau d'or
je milite pas pour cette idée là je dis
simplement que c'est un gigantesque
tabou c'est tout alors il a beau jeu
colloque l'arrivée de pointer du doigt
et de dire regardez c'est le culte du
veau d'or non c'est pas le culte du veau
d'or c'est encore une fois faire sauter
un verrou qui fait qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes malheureux mentale volet
environnemental nous sommes l'homme
malade de l'europe la france ne doit pas
trop j'ai vite on n'a pas notre place
il faut bien nous imaginer qu'on vit sur
un train de vie démesuré qui n'est pas
du tout à l'image de ce que nous sommes
la france est un petit pays j'aime cette
phrase de céline lesage la france et les
deux sèvres
mais bien sûr la france est encore plus
aujourd'hui qu'à l'époque de céline donc
le culte du veau d'or on l'a pas mais ce
serait bien que là tout petit peu plus
mais entre le dire les deux sèvres il
est petit village planétaire qu'on nous
promet est-ce qu'on n'est pas bien dans
les deux sèvres
si on est pas mal dans les deux chèvres
mais il faut sortir des de serre et faut
sortir de cet enfermement nostalgique
moi j ja dopé tennis j'aime pas ça moi
j'aime le monde j'aime embrasser le
monde j'aime internet j'aime la
modernité et
et je crois que finalement le monde il
est libéral et donc au bout d'un moment
il va falloir qu'on droite libérale de
fait on le veuille ou pas colloque le
tableau il à sauter le tabou il a sauté
en eau de la société c'est à dire que le
tabou de la robe de la richesse
faisaient que quand on était riche on se
sentaient obligés d'entreprendre
alors ça c'est le libéralisme est là
dedans ça existe parce qu'un tabou de
l'argent pas un tabou de la marchandise
mais un tabou de l'argent à partir donc
ça saute on est dirigeant de société et
on peut spéculer contre sa propre
entreprise et en bas de la société tabou
de la richesse qu'à sauter c'est les
gamins à l'école
arborant les marques et pour ça il va le
héros de la cité savait que celui qui a
réussi dans la richesse c'est à dire le
caïd
c'est à dire le dealer enchères donc
c'est vrai au passage son analyse
imaginé sur clope il est en train de
dire que c'est pas bien de parler
d'argent parce que il va y avoir dans
les cités des key qui vont arborer des
marques c'est ridicule franchement c'est
une argutie de dame pipi c'est ridicule
il faut en finir avec ça alors j'écoute
vos arguments quand guy konopnicki dit
qu'il y a des propres dirigeants qui
jouent contre leur entreprise oui c'est
vrai on le constate et les gens ça peut
choquer sa ya pas deux d'éthique ou de
morale d'antan bien mais lorsqu'un
accident de voiture vous supprimez pas
toutes les voitures en france il ya des
pourris dans le monde de l'entreprise
c'est évident il faut les sanctionner
davantage que nous donne ce soir mais il
faut pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau du
bain on aimerait d'accord qu'il n'y a
pas une sanction
vu de l'extérieur vu de la part du du
citoyen on n'a pas le sentiment que le
crime financier soient traités à égalité
du crime de sang parce qu'on est un pays
immature qui a une relation pathologique
avec l'argent c'est toujours la même la
même raison chez les anglo saxons ça va
très vite
l'autre jour j'étais à une réunion où il
y avait des journalistes économiques il
y avait un journaliste alors là
de suède qui disait chez nous il y
aurait pas de vos hommes politiques qui
seraient président d'un club de ping
pong dire que dans le monde anglo saxon
dans le monde scandinave
on a la mémoire des choses et on
sanctionne les politiques qui prennent
dans la caisse où les industriels qu'ils
prennent dans la caisse
vous êtes pour les nids et j 10 bits et
c'est à dire quand on était condamné on
dia inéligible et bien évidemment un
système libéral
il est valable qu'à partir du moment où
il est cloisonné ou en tout cas bordure
ai marre des systèmes réglementaires
très fort comme aux états unis comme aux
états c'est pas le cas chez doit donc
maintenant on comprend que les gens
soient un petit peu quand même surpris
de voir ces différences de traitement
non mais oui parce que chez nous
l'argent et c'est toujours la même chose
est tabou même je crois qu'avant on va
on va continuer mais je sens le cgdd a
compris qu'il faut gagner l'argent pour
pourvoir le répartir vous êtes sûr je
pense pas qu'il faille considérer que
les français ne comprennent pas ça mais
justement c'est la répartition qui pêche
et qui provoquent des désordres dans
l'économie puis par ce combat
les gamins ne rêve que de la richesse et
se jette dans les dents dans les pires
comportements et dans la délinquance
voilà mais c'est toujours la même chose
on est dans quelque chose de très fort
c'est l'argent valeur les gamins ne rêve
que de la richesse et deviennent des
délinquants c'est ce qu'il dit en
substance hier que bon ben voilà on est
vraiment dans cette association
qui devient encore fatigante entre la
richesse l'argent et et puis les
comportements délinquants de jeu qu'on
pense que ce que vous dites mais ce que
dit konopnicki c'est que effectivement
il ya une génération qui veut l'argent
et devient désirante tellement désir
entre quelques ultimes de frustration
parce que elle va s'apercevoir un moment
ou un autre il faut le gagner l'argent
mais est ce que vous n'avez pas le
sentiment je pense que vous êtes entouré
d'adolescents que c'est d'abord la
consommation avant le travail l'argent
et la richesse n'exclut pas la morale le
civisme la citoyenneté
mais j'ai la conviction dans un univers
qui devient de plus en plus mouvant où
on voit des apprentis sorciers et des
idéologues de mauvais aloi débarquer un
peu partout je pense que l'économie de
marché
maîtriser comme projet familial c'est
pas un truc si pour x ou y arrive on a
juste pour revenir une dernière fois sur
des éléments d'actualité
admettez que tout un chacun s'étonne
quand on trouve des millions de francs
dans des coffres d'une association
syndicale patronale
les gens sont quand même un petit peu
étonné ce quand on a du mal à finir ses
fins de mois quand on est bon admettez
quand même qu'il ya là de quoi avoir sur
l'argent un regard ou moins
interrogatifs
mais je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous c'est le grand hiatus française
dira qu' on essaie d'avoir une vision
plus moderne de l'économie de marché et
à côté de ça il ya une quantité
considérable de gens qui sont dans la
souffrance et on parle souvent des sdf
mais il ya aussi en france un réservoir
de smicards qui est gigantesque le
salaire minimum dans tous les pays
d'europe ces deux ou trois pour cent des
salariés chez nous' un salarié sur cinq
c'est à dire qu'à aussi cette relative
pauvreté la sirc on est dans une
situation économique encore une fois et
je ne suis pas économiste qui fait que
mon discours peut paraître extrêmement
curieux parce qu'il ya ce décalage
permanent entre le retour des riches
pour lesquels je milite et puis à côté
de ça une pauvreté qui est là qui est
bien réel qui s'enracine
j'ai commencé par une citation alors je
vous en livre est une
hier quelqu'un disait il y a les petits
mensonges les grands mensonges et la
statistique je remercie je parlais donc
on parlait de votre livre être riche
un tabou français de eric brunet paru
chez albin michel puis vous poserez la
question alors est ce que je veux être
riche
à ce prix là
[Musique]